hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast quality by Design
development of a purity method using
uplc and mass detection I'm Gordon
Carlson of waters and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by waters for more
than 50 years Waters Corporation has
developed Innovative analytical science
solutions to support customer
discoveries operations performance and
Regulatory Compliance for more
information please visit
www.waters.com few important
announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the Q
a box which can be found by clicking on
the green q a button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can at
the end of the presentation
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button or
submit your problem through the green q
a button on the lower left
I would now like to introduce today's
speakers Alexander Schmidt and Mio
Stanek are the founders and managing
directors of chromosome gayambeja
a pharmaceutical service provider based
in Berlin Germany
their company specializes in the
development of efficient and robust hplc
and uplc methods Alexander Schmidt is an
expert in the development and validation
of analytical methods applying the very
latest quality by Design approaches he's
the author of more than 50 Publications
and scientific posters as well as being
a guest lecturer at the Butte University
in Berlin
miocenic is also Well published and an
expert in analytical development within
the framework of quality by Design he
specializes in the development of lcms
methods
today we are very fortunate that
Alexander and Mio have taken the time to
describe their quality by Design
approach we hope that you will enjoy
their presentation
yes thank you very much for the
introduction
so let us start with
our presentation
we called we are designing analytical
methods
so the agenda what we would like to
speak today
who we are promising the company
chromisand then we would like to compare
traditional verses
systematic strategies for method
development
and the last Point Neo will show us in
case study quality by without quality by
Design and analytical method
developmental case study
so Who We Are I'm Alexander Schmidt Neil
is sitting next to me and we are the
founder of commission
we have together more than 35 years
experiments
um in the pharmaceutical industry in
developing and validation of upsc and
hplc methods and quality by Design in
analytically instrument qualification
GMP and productivity and efficiency in
queries
we published more than 50 Publications
and presentations on International
congresses and we are very often invited
speakers at conferences
our company chromie centers and
pharmaceutical service provider and we
are offering method development and then
quality by Design framework first
degradation studies for merit
development and impurity profiling
methodation method transfer as well as
Consulting training and GMP auditing
our company is based in Berlin Germany
in in Technology Park which is called
atlasov alasov is one of the biggest
technology parks in Europe and we are
here in we are integrated in network
activities which are called analytic
City address of we are also on the
reference customer and training facility
for the waters Corporation
we have more than 400 for 440 square
meters lab space and by the end of the
year we will have a step of 12. the
equipment which we're using
Alliance hplc systems with different
kinds of detections
um upsc acurity classic age class and I
class systems or sort of different kinds
of detectors includes of a single and
terminal Ms detectors we also have in a
qrt UPC Square which is an ultra
performance sfc system from Waters which
is also connected to the MS detection
and we have automatics and preparation
robot stations and the solution testers
from zotak chromosome attacked
Corporation
the highlights we are currently
developing methods for our mainly small
molecules a lot of generic inclusive
antibiotics and hormones and our bollock
steroids stimulants
pesticides natural components and hydro
carbohydrates
now let us make a comparison to
traditional and various systematic
strategies and Method development
this is mainly done by trial and error
by varying one factor at the time the
problems which could occur if you are
using such a traditional strategy is
that additional or missing Peaks you see
very late in the development process and
trying to test quality and then method
is always the wrong way so
this result is very time consuming and
you have no understanding of the
influential keep vectors
another I would like to give you an
example for this if you are
or here you have the two
parameters X and Y and the in one fact
at the time approach you fix one factor
that is in this case Y and varying the
factor x until you find an working Point
Let's assume that the working point
would be here the black dot
in The Next Step you would
fix the factor x and varying the factor
y until you find another
working point
but what really happened is that the
robust region is next to the working
point you have selected by by the one
factor at the time approach and
therefore you wouldn't find an
invariable robust methods
so what could happen if you have not a
non-robust method
we would like to show you here in some
other grams we received from the Moana
Institute
um
yeah the first chromatogram looks very
nice you have a well separation between
all the Peaks
um the peak symmetry is good
but from day to day or from system to
system you get variations and you can
see that especially in the green box
that something happened
and the question is what happened and
you can see it here in the last
chromatogram
um one Peak was in the second
um
uh in in the last peak in the second
peak of restaurant then at the first
peak of the second chromatogram and
finally it moved out of the Peaks and
now we have the separation of these
three chromatic these three
Peaks and if you find that out um very
late in your development process maybe
in at the validation or maybe when the
product is already on the market you're
in deep trouble with this kind of method
another
um traditional strategy in
um method development meant is to adapt
already existing methods maybe from the
literature or published in in
pharmacopoers
he has an a very nice example of an
official method which was adopted from
the current version of the European
pharmacopoe it is the official method
for a Boston and you can see here that
the runtime is unbelievable 160 minutes
the Peak grid for the absent Peak is
eight minutes and the retention factor
is between
0.25 and 17.
17 sorry that means you have you have
the first peaks eluted with the thousand
and the last Peak it takes forever until
it comes from the column
in comparison to the traditional
approach the systematic method
development approach for example by
using statistical software tools and
that approach here using experimental
design plans
and in a full or an infractional
factorial design you perform a couple of
experiments
um
to find the best method typical software
packages for this is the fusion software
and design expert
in other systematic SC method
development approach is by using
modeling software to it
that is a very smart way in which you
perform only some Center or Corner
experiments and the software tools can
then calculate all the chromatograms
which are within these corners
a typical example are the driver
software Chrome third and from ACD the
LC simulator
finally and that is the approach we
perform here at the commission is the
quality by Design
approach which was
implemented some years ago also in the
ich guidelines Q8 it starts with the
definition of method codes then a risk
assessment the design of experiments
to define the critical quality
attributes and in screening and
optimization
phase you select
the best parameter from all these you
build and design space select the
working Point make a verification and
then start with the validation and
robustness study
the final step is to implement a control
stretch strategy that could be in system
suitability test to make sure that the
method is always robust and working in
your lab
Mio is giving us now in in a study how
we perform suction method development in
our lab Neo
so first again the initial situation
like we have seen before the official
hplc method foreign
so first we have to decide what are our
goals the first is we wanted to use uplc
technology to be much more faster
and in the second part we want to use
for the screening hypothesis statistical
software fusion and for the optimization
part the modeling software dry lab
so again the the slide
with all these five steps we implemented
in our approach
first Define method goals
what we want to have is a separation of
all components with the resolution
higher 2.0
minimum analysis time
should be lower than 10 minutes
the K star values for the API and the
impurities between 2 and 10. and what we
want to have is a design space that we
can visualize that we can touch
so step two risk assessment where we
have defined all critical parameters
that are the columns
the gradient time the temperature
Tannery composition of the element
pH of the element and Slot percent B and
N percent B
next step design of experiments where we
screen four columns there are more than
thousand different columns on the market
and on the water's home page we can find
these
graph with many different columns
and on a selectivity chart you can see
the hydro hydrophobicity against the
selectivity and all these blue dots are
columns and what we wanted to do is to
use uplc technique and therefore we need
sub 2 micro atoms
and normal and if we use them Waters
uplc columns all these gray and red dots
are available columns from waters for
you PLC on the market and we decided to
take these four columns why why we have
to use the these four columns first we
use the bhc18 column that's a very
robust column
and try to find orthogonal columns that
are available on the market for this we
used a BH for new column with a very
similar selectivity but a very
um
different hydrophobicity
and very orthogonal to the frenulum
column is the hssc 18 SB column with the
same hydrophobicity but a different
selectivity and because we use the 2dh
columns that's why we choose the ahss T3
column to have two
BH columns and two H Edith columns
so all these experiments were run by the
age class why the H class because
um
you have the chance to take to to use
nine different solvers like three
organic solvents and six different PHS
well you can use with the color manager
up to six different columns with
different temperature zones and we use
the PDA detector and the qda single Ms
detector for Peak tracking
so implementing the benefits of two
software tools
for the screening part we have used the
fusion software
where the softwares automatically
implementing all the methods and Empower
writing all your instrument methods your
method sets your sample set and so on
with this software you can use all your
six different columns and nine different
organic solvents automatically and with
the software you can use a brighter
parameter range
so like for the pH where you can use
from pH 2 to 14 for example
and for the optimization part we use the
dry lab where we have to run only only
few runs unnecessary
the variation of flow rate start percent
B and N percent B
it's possible to run without experiments
within the software
and with Riley we can receive predicted
chromatograms for example
um
the software showing you how the
chromatogram should like
and the robustness testing we can make
in Silicon where also no runs are
not needed to do
so next step screaming power with Fusion
first we have to create a design
um we have fixed three parameters the
flow rate the star percent B and the N
percent B because the variation is later
possible with rylab without uh
performing some runs
and we have some variable parameters
where we used aceto Nitro methanol
isopropanol and for pH we used all the
range from two to seven
the power the temperature is 35 to 70
degrees
the gradient Time 5 to 10 minutes and
the four different columns with the same
parameters like we have shown before
so next part building the design of
experiments the software is now creating
your completely sample set where we have
78 different
um yeah chromatograms or runs
and after implementing it in software we
have to run new experiments and what you
get is
four different design spaces
um where we have to choose as our
parameters or our critical quality
attributes like the resolution between
all your our Peaks the
number of Peaks the Symmetry factor or
the retention time of your last Peak
and everywhere we have net our goals the
area should be white so you can see with
the
hssc18sb column
there's no
um and there's no possibility to get a
nice chromatogram with the goals where
we have decided
and with the pH the aching column this
column have the biggest white area so we
should take the bhc 18 column to the
optimization part
so
um selection of parameters for the
optimization we are fixed again the flow
rate the star percent P the N percent p
and this time normally the column the
bhc 18
and the variable parameters are now
um acetonitrile and isopropanol the pH
should be is tested with a
5.8 and 6.8
the temperatures again from 35 degrees
to 70 degrees and the gradient time is a
little bit shorter with three to nine
minutes
so for the optimization phase the design
of experiments were done with a dry lab
where we have chosen two different
temperatures two different gradient
times and three different ternary
composition of l1b
with acetonitrile and isopropanol
and on the first layer we can see a
our design space with 100 aceto Nitro
where we can see the gradient time
against the temperature
and let me explain you a little bit the
color code
the red
color shows a resolution higher than 2.0
and the nearly black area shows you a
resolution with uh zero
and all the colors between
red and black are the resolution between
0 and 2.0 and here we can see with 100
acetro nitrile we don't receive a
resolution with higher than 2.0
but when we increase the amount of
isopropanol to 30 percent we get with a
higher temperature red area where
2.0
but with 60 isoproponal we get almost
the red area so this shows us that
everywhere we can choose with the
temperature or the gradient time we get
the resolution higher than 2.0
but when we combine all the three layers
we get the cube but in this Cube we see
all the other different colors but by
resetting the parameters
we receive a big red area and that is
our design space now if we can choose
our working Point somewhere in the
middle
we can choose
somewhere in the middle
so next step would be to test the
influence of the pah
this time real and time against pH
R from 5.8 to 6.8 and what we get is
again a design space a red area
where um
on all our components have a resolution
higher than 2.0 but
uh the black areas this time a
resolution 1.5 that means
all the colors between black red are the
resolution between 1.5 and 2.0 and
that's the edge of the failure that
means if you choose your working point
on the edge of a failure you are close
to the
um
is not working anymore
so what we have done is the verification
of the model with real experiments where
we have chosen our working point and run
the experiment and six different
verification points around our working
point
um you can see the dry lab predicted
retention time against the experimental
retention plan but there are too many
numbers to compare so what we have done
to make a graph with the predicted
retention time against the experimental
retention times and when what we get is
a correlation coefficient of
0.9996 that means that our predicted
design space is true and very good
The Next Step would be method validation
Alexander
it has a method validation study was
performed in accordance to the ich
Skyline Q2 of course
and with the
um
the first steps specificity linearity
accuracy prediction
and the last step in the method
validation study you know which is the
method robustness
we always recommend to do the robustness
study in before you perform the
validation study just in case that you
find some issues which make us necessary
to move your working point in in some
directions
so in in this case we had optimized six
parameters and in a full factorial
design with three levels we had Tom
three to the power of six that means 729
experiments
I think nobody is performing this and
then method validation study
um but we used the previous designed
um design space our model for the
robustness testing and by using the dry
lip software we can do this in silica
that is a very nice the feature in the
new dry lab version 4.0 to perform the
robustness testing in silico
for your results of these 729
experiments you can see here only the
first 10 runs and the the last 10 runs
and in the last column you can see the
critical resolution between all critical
Peak path and there are some the
resolution is always higher than 2.0 for
all experiments that means the method is
very robust
last step in our development
um
step is our strategy is to implement the
control strategy
and because the method is so robust we
choose the resolution of the critical
people which we identified as in prtc
and d as in system suitability
parameter and that was all for our
control strategy
and here now you can see the final UPAC
method which we developed by using
Fusion for the screening and dry lab for
the optimization you can see a very nice
separation of all impurity Peaks from
the API the invest in
and the runtime is only four minutes
and here once again the comparison of
the final method against the official
upsc method
the official method from the European
pharmacopoe 160 minutes
and
our new develop method for minutes
so conclusion all previous defined
method goes where met
we have a shift Baseline separation of
all components of interest within the
resolution higher than 2.0
the retention Factor values forever
investment and impurities are between
2.2 and 4.3 whether it's perfect fits
into the
um tend to No 1 to 20 value range
the
um
design space is visualized
and the analysis time is only four
minutes that's an impressive 44th
increase in the productivity and
comparison to the
method published in the European
pharmacopoe and it allows testing for
more than 360 samples per day in
comparison to eight samples of the oil
method
yeah that's it
thank you very much for your interest
and if you have any questions please let
us know
thank you Alexander and Mio for that
informative presentation the
presentation and PDF files of the
presentation will be sent to All
attendees
and now I would like to just remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit by typing them in the Q a box
which can be found by clicking on the
green q a button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
our first question
which type of regression model do you
use to explore and Define the design
space
I don't really know because we used only
the fusion version for
um for non-experts so Fusion gives you
basic options so it takes a statistical
designs for you so you don't have to
choose what kind of model that's only in
the expert version
so I hope I've answered the question for
dry lab there is no um
model there are only calculations were
done
next question
if you're using an MS detector is
resolution still a critical parameter
the MS data will provide masses for coal
leading Peaks
and this is only for Peak Tracking not
for the resolution so we can see where
the Peaks are moving
to explore the space for the composition
of the eluent in the three components do
you use D optimal design
no there's only I think in statistical
it's a d optimal design and like I said
before I don't really know what Fusion
is doing behind
so that was only for
um the non-expert version we used
and dry lab is not using uh the optimal
designs
have you used the pqri database for
column selection or screening
um yes we have
um but you will get just the number for
for the comparison of the all these
columns and we prefer in graphic
comparison and that's the reason why we
used
um the
um the column selectivity part on the
web what does the web page we think it's
just easier to to see and to handle
could you please comment on The Matrix
effect using this type of method
development
I don't know if I really understand this
question there was no Matrix effect
because it was only the API and the
impurities
can separations using mixed mode hplc
columns be modeled with this software
no as far as I know the right lip
software can only
make calculations with a reversed phase
in the reverse phase mode and normal
phase
but not not a combination of that
as far as I know
while designing design of experiment
methods when do you select partial
factorial and when do we select full
factorial
easy to answer when for experiments are
full factorial so we do full factorial
it depends how much parameters do you
have the more parameters you have you
need much more experiments to make a
full factorial design so full factorial
that only makes sense for a number of
parameters
when you develop a method in Fusion how
do you track unknown peaks of interest
from degradation for example trying to
get a stability indication method
we have also looked for unknown but uh
the unknown the impurities from the
degradation are uh mostly these known
impurities but after that we have also a
test on uh forced degradation impurities
so
Peak tracking with this software is it
automated or do you need to manually
assign the Peaks
pick tracking is manually when we use
dry lab because the software doesn't
know how the peak is moving
does the software calculate the
probability of the model designed for
you according to your input and validate
it at the end as well
no of course not you have to validate
um your final method it's up to you
where you're walking working point in
your design space is so the the
validation study has to perform by the
user after the the selection of the
working Point verification study
how is the qda used to for Peak tracking
and Purity analysis
you have the qda is very useful in um to
see where your Peaks are moving so
sometimes you have impurities which are
very similar to the or the the Spectra
of the impurities are very similar to
the main Peak so if you have to make an
Peak tracking to see where you um
whether the movements or where your Peak
moves you you need more data than only
the UV Spectra and in this case as the
qda detects was very useful
were the 729 experiments actually
simulations or or were they performed
experimentally
the only simulations because we have
verificated the working point and six
different verification points we showed
that our design space our simulations
are true so there was no need for do
some other experiments for the
robustness testing only to use the
software
so are there any situations where Fusion
or dry Labs should not be used in
simulation processes
at this moment I don't know any part
where there are not usable so but we
haven't checked everything what's
possible
how long does it take to complete the
total process from start to finish
it depends sometimes um three
days
sometimes a week and inclusively the
validation study in in two weeks we are
finished with with method development
and validation
we are doing only uh for developing one
method
how do you deal with unknown mixtures
where you might not know all of the
components or alternatively do you need
to know the composition of a mix to do
optimization
no there's no need to to know the
molecules of course it's it's in help if
you know what kind of molecules you have
but the fusion end of the right lip
software you don't need to know what
that is you can separate the mixture
without knowing
um the the molecules which are in the
mixture
how did you come up with the range in
the design space for the fusion
experiments
uh the Rangers are um
you are deciding in the beginning
um what is your lower and your higher
limit and
the slides are showing you have to
choose to fix some parameters and then
you have the to degraph where you can
choose your working or changing the
fixed parameters for example pH not at
pH five then you can change to six and
see what's happening then in your slide
you know 2D graph
are there any guidelines to set the
relative standard deviation in
impurities analysis
you know the ich guidelines of course
um are giving you some advice and
impurities and what the specifications
are
um but I don't know if the relative
standard deviation is part of these mych
guidelines so
um I would advise check the ich
guideline um QA and QC please
could the design space be used to define
a method in the M.A dossier in order to
let the laboratory have more flexibility
in the analyzes
for example in the case of a transfer to
QC
yeah that's exactly what we are doing so
we have a working point but also in
range and we put this information in our
addresses so that in the case of a
method transfer to quality control or to
a different lab you can use this
information
do you have any advice for injecting a
sample with high percentage of organic
in a method development strategy where
you start with a very low
um organic
composition it's it's a little bit
tricky
so at the moment I don't
know what what could be done without
diluting of course as a sample
have you submitted any modeling data to
regulatory
such as FDA or EMA and what was the
response
we submitted our approach our strategy
to some European National regulators and
they accepted it
um about any questions in the for the
analytic and development and validation
study so it was perfect
columns in the screenings of polar
compounds
no we haven't
is there any software which is able to
design the experiments for sample
preparation time optimization like
sonication shaking
Etc
yes we are doing we are using design
experts software for sustainable
preparation and also we have an
automatic sample preparation robots
station to perform all the experiments
in our experiments plan
do you have some more examples other
than ebosene to support quality by
Design
yeah sure of course so a lot of more and
if you check our names
um uh on the internet at Google for
example you will find more examples one
was published for example in the AC GC I
think it was in the February issue of
this this year North America and in
September in Europe
so there's a lot of examples published
events were run using the fusion AE
software
for the screening part we used we needed
78 different experiments
when do I choose between fusion or dry
lab for method development are both
necessary
no but we wanted to use the benefits of
both softwares softwares there's for in
my opinion no software that you can say
it's the best software so we use the
benefits of one and the benefit of the
other software to get much better design
or a faster way to for qbd
I have used dry lab for LC method
development with good agreement between
the predicted and actual data do you
have any experience for GC method
development
no only LC and sfc
I'm interested in your comment regarding
using the fusion software to create your
Empower methods can you describe this
process in a little more detail
Fusion is working with a toolkit in
Empower and all the runs methods sample
sets instrument methods are written from
Fusion in the Empower software so you
only have to
open the sample set and run the whole
sample set the process but the
processing method have to do have to be
done by yourself
and then again implementation of the
results set in Fusion again
do you have any data on design expert
software
yes but only for sample preparation
but these data are not published yet
so it's only for us and for our
customers we have made some data
you know the impurity molecules but you
don't succeed in separating them for
example you don't succeed to separate
imp from impy but you can see that
they're colluding using qda mass data
can use this as an input in dry lab or
fusion and if so how
yes you can use that in dry labs this
information just type in the same
retention time for for the API and your
your impurity and then
the dry lab software realized that you
have a co-illusion of two components
does the software work for sample set
creation and mass links as well or only
in power
I think this question was for Fusion
software I don't really know ask the S
metrics
yeah you know um as in from
pharmaceutical service provider we only
use Empower software in this not the
mouse link so we have no idea if that
works or if fusions of a world will work
also if
the modeling software
sorry
the fusion that you uh talk about is
only only works with Empower masslinks
does not uh support is not supported by
that
if you don't have any software can you
also apply quality by Design approach
for your method development
it's difficult
you can handle all these Peaks and
chromatograms
um I'm not really sure it looks like
then more like a trial and error
how do you evaluate the method predicted
by dry lab
you know we used an um verification
study so dry lab is giving us an um is
showing us the best method or Justin
method and so we can make a comparison
between the retention time of the
prediction and the retention time in an
experiment and so we get the
verification if the model is accurate or
not
and
um we we just saw it in our slides
the comparison is about
99.9 so very very good
okay sure um now one more question
before we close up for the day where is
the software available
by The molna Institute
um here in Berlin Germany
the weapon dresses
institute.com and the few softwares are
available from s metrics in San Diego
California
and I think the laptop dresses s minus
metrics.com
well unfortunately we are out of time
we're going to get back to any
unanswered questions later on we hope
that you found Alexander's and Mio's
presentation valuable
if you'd like to learn more about their
quality by Design approach to LC methods
you can reach them at chromasent.de
there are also a number of scientific
downloads on this webinar's registration
page
as mentioned before a PDF of the
presentation will be sent to All
attendees and the webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April of 2015.
you'll receive an email from labroots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for reply
we invite you to forward the
announcement to all of your colleagues
who may have missed this today's live
event see you next time and goodbye